Okay, so we're in the Sprint mode here - the second of the Beta Sprints,
an amazing group represented by Rachel Frick
and some colleagues coming up on stage.
There's someone who has not been mentioned yet,
but deserves it, Don Waters,
he was a founding member of the steering committee
and he made a grant to CLIR and company to develop this
Beta Sprint but I think it speaks to the model to develop for the DPLA
of course that the system itself is supported
and we need to sustain that, but also grants might be made to
partner organizations to do things like what Rachel and crew have done.
Thank you for this great opportunity and of course,
I am embarrassed by making my colleagues stand
while I've ramble on for seven minutes.
I'm Rachel Frick, and I'm the director of the Digital Library Federation at the
Council of Library and Information Resources
and I'm happy to talk about the CLIR-DLF/IMLS DCC Beta Sprint
full of acronyms, let's go. Basically, what we started with,
is building a metadata aggregation that represented
thousands of cultural heritage collections across the US.
We did this by combining existing data collections -
one of them being the IMLS DCC,
and IMLS is the Institute of Museum and Library Services.
This was started to provide a single point of access
to the content that was funded by the IMLS.
Another resource that we used was another collection,
metadata collection called Opening History.
This is an aggregation that is guided by a clearly defined
collection of policy unit and it builds off the DCC content
but it's a base of history collections that extends
beyond the funded content to include other content aggregations.
We used those two collections of aggregations plus others
to build our DPLA prototype.
What resulted was a collection of metadata that
represented 1400 collections of over 1 million items from
over 1200 institutions in 44 states
and we were grateful to the chief officers of state
library agencies to help coordinate some of this content.
As a result, our scope broadened as result of the variety of
collecting institutions that contributed to this
aggregation as you can see here.
Our work has also been informed by a strong body of research on information seeking
in libraries, archives and digital collections
as well as research on metadata data quality and collection.
One of the problems with large aggregation, retaining a rich collection content
and helping users comprehend the sea of items
that lie behind a single search box.
These are technical and conceptual problems that grow as your aggregation grows.
But at the same time, when you aggregation grows
You're able to surface new national strengths within this
collective collection and bring to the surface small
collections otherwise might be hidden.
Our particular aggregation collection had this
particular topical strings including the local history of cities
and towns throughout the US, military history,
Civil War and World War II, arts, Native American history,
architecture, women's history, and agriculture and ranching.
Our prototype allows users to search within a vast array
of cultural heritage that has been digitized over the last few decades.
Collections and their metadata are key to providing people with intellectual
and navigational context for it especially as they
explore and evaluate materials.
Collections in and of themselves are meaningful organizational units that
can bring coherence and functionality to amass individual items.
And like -- systems that tend to lose this type of
collection context, we actually try to exploit that.
We preserve that I don't with this collection context.
That is often lost in the flatter searches.
In Beta Sprint, we also provided an opportunity for users to link to
and make use of secondary sources.
So here is where everyone from the University of Illinois is
going to take a collective deep breath, because I'm going to a live demonstration here.
I really wanted to show you some of the great work.
We're highlighting collections up in our banner and here is a link to our cute little video,
and over here you can see the number of items, collections
and institutions represented in this aggregation
And these are live links you can click.
You can also navigate by states and here you can see Utah,
we have 70 collections there, Arizona, 84.
I don't know what is going on with the Dakotas,
but we're working on it.
I am doing a shout out to the Dakotas.
Also, you can browse by date
and the colors represent the density of objects
and so the more objects we have,
the darker the colors and you can search by item type
and have also drawn us of other things like entries from
-- which we highlight different items in the collection.
And you can find us on Flickr. That being done,
I'm going to go back to,
I am not going to do a search because I have two minutes
but we encourage you to go to our Beta Sprint site
and search for yourself.  That being said,
it is beyond just our website and prototype
and aggregation there is also a lot of research,
novel and innovative ways of visualizing analyzing connecting
aggregations to user services ongoing process happening.
One of the examples is the idea of topic modeling to help
us refine and analyze metadata.
The other area of interest, they think is interesting,
how does this connect us to think of the data world?
Currently aggregation serves hundreds of cultural
heritage collection level descriptions
and item records available through OAI PMH rate into
large organizations that link to the data,
they can help you extract larger cultural heritage
community by publishing collection level descriptions
and links open data client formats by connecting these
descriptions to existing open data sources this
aggregation serves as a bridge to collections which are
currently hidden for the link stated in our great state
great example of a service the data can do besides being centralized.
All right then without color line to stop open for
questions. Here is the first URL to Beta Sprint
and the one below us to our project website that has a lot of documentation
and further information about our activities.
We want to thank the IMLS
for their support for digital collections and research and aggregation,
none of this work would have been possible. So thank you.
[Applause]
Questions?
My question is,
there are a lot of cultural institutions in the United
States. And this is an example,
there is a small public library is organized by the mayonnaise system.
And I am wondering if you had a screening process for he
was included in your project.
If there is an international association of crackpots,
for example, would you link to them?
I will answer that and you can correct me.
The aggregation,
it was IMLS funded projects that got the inclusion
and Opening History has a collection of policy that you can
link to that is very important to have a huge aggregation,
with what you include what you are talking about so there
are things outlined in that collection
and right now the TP alleges not have a collection
development policy that we have a content
and scope of work stream to help guide the content is
going to be other going to have updates from the work
stream this afternoon to help answer your question.
I had it back unfair it is actually,
DPLA for the Beta Sprint to look at the site it is  DPLA . Granger.
.Illinois.EDU.
DPLA,
there is a blogger page  that has hit list of all of the
Beta Sprint that have been made public
and to encourage everyone to find all of them as well.
RIP -- all right. Sorry you don't get to answer questions.
You can reach us on the Internet, like you said.
Thanks. [Applause]